[موسيقى]
علاقتنا بالمناخ علاقه حياتيه وحياتنا
متوقفه عليه ونحن ما ناكل ولا نشرب ولا
نلبس ولا نسكن الا على مجرياته والاكل
ينقسم عندنا الى قسمين اكل صيفي واكل شتوي
الصيفي اغلبه مشروب الحليب واللبن ومنه
قولهم الصيف ضيعت اللبن والشتوي اغلبه
ماكول وعناصره ثلاثه التمر والسمن والدقيق
يا وليدي تراي مريت ما ضريت عليك باللي
اكله دويف وناره ليف ولا تقربا لاكله تمر
وناره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واكلنا من بيئتنا المرقوق الجريش الكليجه
العصيده والعريكه وعناصرها ثلاث التمر
والسمن والبر ففي نهايه موسم الحميمين
يكون عندنا وفره
لا تامن القرد دام البر بالبر وفي نهايه
موسم سهيل يكون عندنا وفره بالتمر لا دخل
سهيل تلمس التمر بالليل وفي نهايه موسم
العقارب يكون عندنا وفره بدسم ولهذا سميت
عقرب الدسم بين قوسين السمن فخلاله تكون
البهم حمله اللحوم والشحوم على ظهورها
لحومهم لحمي وهم ياكلونه وما داهيات المرء
الا
اقاربه
[موسيقى]